let's bring in the IRS agent's attorney
Mark Lytle Mark thanks for being here
Brett thanks for having me first of all
why is your client not coming forward
publicly why don't why can't we know who
he is so Brett great question uh there
are laws in place uh federal laws that
protect the privacy of taxpayers and
taxpayer information they're very
specific about what can be said and what
can't be said and under what
circumstances that can take place
my client wants to specifically follow
those laws and they involve certain
procedures in particular When
approaching Congress there's only
specific committees that are allowed or
that are empowered to Grant this uh
Authority for a whistleblower to come
forward to talk about taxpayer
information so when someone says maybe
this is politically motivated how do you
respond to that well I can say we are
not able to talk about any particular
cases and
um there there's no my client wants to
come forward he's not a political person
he's not a social media person he's not
coming here with a political agenda he's
been at the IRS for a long time he's
been the IRS for more than 10 years as
and now he's a supervisory special agent
he's been trusted at the IRS he's uh
he's actually been trusted as an
assistant special agent in charge in
other cities and trusted with
International investigations and working
with other countries tax enforcement uh
bureaus you sent this letter
to the Senate the finance and ranking of
the finance committee Judiciary both
whistleblower protection and Chuck
Grassley also to the house Ways and
Means chairman the ranking Jim Jordan
Jerry Nadler and Judiciary and in it it
says that your client has
information that contradicts sworn
testimony to Congress by senior
political appointee failure to mitigate
clear conflicts of interest and ultimate
disposition of this case that you're
talking about and examples of
preferential treatment and politics
improperly infecting decisions as laid
out in this letter is there
documentation to support this not just
someone saying this is what I saw but
actual documentation yes Brett so my
client's a career law enforcement
officer who is respected within the IRS
and he teaches other agents how to
properly do investigations he knows when
to spot when other invest when
investigative steps aren't done in the
traditional way to get at the truth and
he is spotted and observed things that
are done differently in in this
particular matter which I can't identify
and he wants to talk about them and he
believes that they were influenced by
politics you can't identify but we have
sources telling us that this has to do
with the hunter Biden investigation and
to that point Hunter Biden's attorney
Chris Clark put out a statement in which
he says it appears this IRS agent has
committed a crime it is a felony for an
IRS agent to improperly disclose
information about an ongoing tax
investigation the IRS has incredible
power in abusing That Power by targeting
embarrassing or disclosing him for
information about a private Citizen's
Tax Matters undermines Americans faith
in the federal government unfortunately
that is what has happened and is
happening here in an attempt to harm my
client you know it's really unfortunate
that that statement was made
um you know uh Mr Clark made that
statement my client wrestled with
whether or not to come forward he had a
lot of sleepless nights about coming
forward with this at the end of the day
he decided that he could not live with
himself if he stayed quiet and said
nothing so he's coming forward but he
knows that he's going to be attacked and
you know really attacks like this are
kind of what he was worried about but he
wants to come forward tell the truth
he's instructed us to reach out to both
Democrats and Republicans on the hill
and let those statements that if they
want to hear him and have them come in
to the hill and talk to him let those
statements rest where they are I mean
you see that as fairly threatening that
that you know I don't think it helps uh
you know I don't think it helps
whistleblowers as a whole I mean uh
there there is a strong contention on
the hill that believes in The
Whistleblower programs uh to have to
shine a light on government agencies and
programs and to enable people to come
forward without getting threatened and
it's unfortunate that that statement was
made you mentioned Democrats and
Republic plugins both were asked about
it today here's a some sound from a
couple of them
there is facts and evidence that
contradict sworn testimony before
Congress is is a five alarm fire when it
comes to any potential investigation and
the politicization of these agencies we
take all whistleblowers statements
seriously as we should some turn out to
be very important and some not but we
take them all seriously at the outset
and look at them closely
so you've requested this whistleblower
protection is there is that advanced
from that request yesterday we sent the
letter out uh to the various committees
that uh have these authorities uh we
have received Outreach this morning and
we're in current dialogue we haven't
received Outreach from every committee
but we've received dialogue from some of
the Committees and we're we're in a
dialogue with what what's next steps to
take a positive dialogue positive
dialogue expressing interest to come
forward uh one of the things my client
insists on is that he only come in to
talk to both Democrats and Republicans
and they can all ask them questions and
cross-examine them and he has documents
that'll support what he has to say one
of the difficulties about tax secrecy
laws tax privacy laws are some some of
the things he can't tell me as his
lawyer uh without and so we've
instructed them don't do that we want to
have them follow those laws Congress can
enable him to do that last thing this is
the White House one of the lists is
contradicting sworn testimony to
Congress by senior political appointee
there's a lot of reporting out there
that this may be the Attorney General
take a listen to the White House today
is the president
holds all the ethical obligations here
when it comes to
me again the president has always been
cleared during the campaign during his
presidency that the Department of
Justice should have Independence they
should not be politicized and they
should be able to do their job
independently essentially
whether
the Attorney General said something on
Capitol Hill could be at matter I know
you can't talk about the specifics but
does your client think that this what
he's coming forward with is explosive is
jarring so I can't talk specific about
who it was that my client's talking
about and I know there's been a lot of
reporting and I can't address that what
I can say is a career law enforcement
officer who knows the right way to do an
investigation when he hears a senior a
politically appointed official at the
department of justice under sworn
testimony say something and in his mind
it's directly contradictory to what he
knows is going on with the investigation
and what he can prove with documents
what he can prove with documents he
wants to come forward
Mark Lytle we appreciate your time and
if your client wants to come forward
when he does we'd love to have him
thanks Brett